after several fatal terror attacks hit
London last year the mayor of that say
Sadiq Khan who is a demagogue tried to
placate his critics by saying that
overall London is the world's safest
city London is the safest global city in
the world
and one of the safest cities in the
world but we are very safer a city that
was false then it's ridiculous now a
wave of stabbings have given London a
higher murder rate than New York City
which is much bigger on Thursday six
teenagers were stabbed in London and
four separate incidents over just 90
minutes why is this happening why is it
accelerating Katie Hopkins a lifelong
resident of the UK calling us at the
rebel author of rude joins us now with
an explanation Katie what's going on in
London it doesn't it just make you your
skin cruel to hear that London Mayor
still trotting out and just two days ago
the same lines London is one of the
safest cities and if you go amongst
London right now and talk to regular
people talk to regular people in Britain
they wouldn't dream of taking their
young people to London because we now
have a higher murder rate than New York
we have a major problem with black gangs
in different areas of London in
different postcode zip code regions
black gangs rival black gangs are
killing each other and that figure you
mentioned six in 24 hours of what
actually went up to nine stabbings
yesterday and for every stabbing carried
out by one tribe one gang that will be
revenged there will be vengeance for
that so it's a perpetuating crime level
and it's a crime wave we're going to see
rising and it's a serious problem here
in London that the mayor and the head of
the Met work talk about it because it
involves young black men and they're too
afraid of being called racist well
that's it right there I mean Londoners
had crime problems in centuries past at
various points but what's changed is the
unwillingness of the people in charge to
acknowledge it and their willingness
instead to lie about it and punish
anyone else who doesn't lie about it so
when he says the live at London is the
safest global city how do people respond
in London do they kind of not in a
bovine way oh yeah of course it is no
absolutely not in fact there's quite a
campaign and it's building now to get a
Sadiq Khan out and I see myself as one
of the cheerleaders of that campaign of
course frankly if little Sadiq Khan
could take off his ballet shoes and his
tutu and stop dancing around the issue
and addressed the problem head-on we
have a problem with black gangs in
London these are a syndicated crime
gangs in different areas attacking each
other we need to do profiling of the
attackers then we need to quadruple our
stop and search efforts he got into
power saying he would do his best to
stop stop and search because it unfairly
targeted young black men well I say
tough luck if young black men are the
guys mostly committing this crime then
young black men can expect to be stopped
and searched and frankly if it was white
conservative women doing the stabbing
I'd be very happy to be searched every
day if it saved alive but this lot are
so politically correct they are prepared
to let London for let young boys die on
the street slaughtered every night here
because they don't want to be called
racist and I think that's a thickening
state of affairs here in the UK but it's
a very recognizable theme for that for
us over here Katie Hopkins thank you for
that I appreciate it good luck with a
cream jacket